- What's up, what's up?
Alright, let's see what's going on.
You know, Rowlan just gave you some love.
Meanwhile, he puts
DRock's name in the song.
"Babin" rhymes with a lot of stuff!
"Stabbin'"...
We gotta hit up 21 Savage.
♫ I said I'm D. Rock with the lyrics
♫ I shoot everything walking
♫ I'm all precision, bad decisions
♫ Taught the language I'm talking
♫ I'm chalking white lines
♫ For the labels who said
I'll never turn heads
♫ The type of dudes I leave on seen
♫ Cause they once left me on read
(slow piano musical intro)
(upbeat hip hop music)
(laughs)
- So I just posted...
First of all, what's up?
Wednesday morning...
Happy New Year to all my
Jewish friends out there.
Wednesday morning, just landed, 11:41.
Got a ton of sleep, you
probably saw the little
grainy video that I made on the flight.
Couldn't sleep last night. (clears throat)
Did a lot of work in the hotel room,
so mainly slept on this flight.
Pretty uneventful...
Pretty uneventful flight,
just got some Z's in.
I have like 7 to 13
substantial business fires,
which rarely happens,
maybe 7 nights a year...
Effect me enough that I need
to address it right away.
I couldn't, aka sleep,
and one of the reasons
I sleep so well is 'cause
I only focus on positivity.
I don't let my head go,
and it was interesting...
As I wasn't able to sleep
and then jumped into work,
I'm like, "Oh shit, this is what happens
to everybody around everything."
And no wonder nobody fucking sleeps.
(laughs) Everybody's staying up at night.
I'm telling you...
And by the way, the reason I'm
already in a good mood just
you know, 12 hours later,
or 24 hours later, is...
Positivity always wins.
Like, I'm obsessed.
Why do I start this episode
or end this episode,
however you're doing it, with this rant?
It's because I really think
mindset is everything,
and so you've gotta really decide...
Are you gonna be positive about things,
or negative about things?
Am I thrilled that I have the
ability to do things about it
to make what I'm worried about better?
Or am I crippled by
"Shit, there's like these
seven things I need to fix tomorrow?"
I always choose positivity.
I look at other people around me,
it's not just about me, that are winning.
They choose positivity.
I look at the people around
me that are not winning,
that are not progressing,
that are not advancing.
They're choosing negativity.
It's stunningly binary.
It's stunningly black and white.
It's stunningly A or B.
This is really up to you, and really...
To be very honest, to be
very frank, I think the
biggest impact I'm having
as I read all the emails
'cause I read a lot of
them last night, as well,
is shifting that mindset and
getting people into that,
and making them understand
that they're in charge of that
and hacking and trying to
pour out the negativity...
Dump a negativity, add a positivity,
dump a negativity, add a positivity,
dump a negativity, add a positivity.
I'm a positivity to your world.
That's what I'm pushing, that's my agenda,
and that's why I think
you're feeling the effects.
And I think you need to find more of that
in your partner, in your loved one,
in your business partner,
in your audience.
So many people get 49
comments, 48 are phenomenal,
one's like, "You're a piece of shit,"
and they spend 80% of their
time on that one comment.
Please choose positivity.
Fuck negativity.
Instagram, good morning.
Good morning, good morning.
Hello, everybody.
I had a few minutes, here.
Caught up on work, so I
figured I'd say "What's up."
60 Second Club, good to see you.
Also, while I've got a thousand of you...
October 9th, Columbus Day...
Actually, vlog, for you guys
as well, let's do this double.
October 9th, Columbus Day,
charity wine event in New Jersey.
Get your Ubers Connecticut,
New York, and Pennsylvania.
Get your party buses
if you've got friends.
Unbelievable day. I'll put
a link here in YouTube.
For everybody here, go to winelibrary.com.
Right on the top, it's the top
banner on mobile and desktop.
The Super Tasting.
All the proceeds goes to the
Crohn's & Colitis Foundation.
Obviously means a lot to me and my dad
'cause AJ has Crohn's Disease.
I will be there.
A lot of people have
been trying to figure out
how to get a selfie or hang out with me.
This is $100 way, and with the $100
you get to taste 700 wines.
It's a ridiculous night.
Babin, you're coming?
- [Tyler] Yeah, I get off at (inaudible)
- Everybody's coming, kinda, right?
- I think so.
- From Team Gary?
- It's phenomenal, remarkable.
I really, really, really, really
want you there, Instagram.
Appreciate all the hearts
that are coming right now.
The Super Tasting, make sure you're there.
It's going to be lit.
Just wanna take two last seconds
before I sign off right now
'cause I just got a text that
I have to address back at the office...
This community means
the fucking world to me.
Your likes and comments are my oxygen.
If you're not subscribed
to the vlog, get on it.
We're really crushing Daily Vee,
and please keep tagging your
friends on the comments.
All this new awareness
just keeps feeding me.
(makes gobbling sounds)
I don't need your money,
I need your stuff.
I just appreciate your attention,
the admiration, and your time.
Means the absolute world to me.
(kissing sounds)
(photo shudder sounds)
(reflective piano music)
And I'm just completely refocused
and focused on that right now.
Period.
It's already over.
It's already over the, like, initial push
of, like, being one of those brands.
Now it's gonna be who's best,
and that plays out over
the next 24 months.
And to be very frank with you, Ryan,
I'm so obsessed with audio
and being a player in that.
Like, there's a lot of things
running through my mind.
I'm just really looking at finances.
What I can afford, how can I do it?
Listen, I wanna get
together with you ASAP,
and like, give you my full braindom.
You're gonna be fired up.
We're gonna be fucking
crushing, but it's gonna be...
Like, I need to do all the things that
I need to do over the next six, three...
Four to six months to
feel good about offense.
Make sense?
Just got done with a quick call
with Ryan Harwood, CEO of PureWow.com.
Very amazing modern-day media company,
publisher in the female demo.
Enjoying working with him.
Great dude, we're about to
hit our one year in January.
Very focused on Vayner
X, not just VaynerMedia.
The publishing world is super exciting.
(reflective piano music)
(inaudible mumbling)
(calm hip hop music)
I'm just gonna read a quick YouTube,
and let me leave you with
this little YouTube comment.
Make sure you're commenting, crew.
Wanna get you guys on the show.
291 just got put up a little bit ago.
Let's see...
Let's see what's going on.
Ah, first comment, "I just turned 29.
This whole 'close your eyes
until 29' is incredible.
Super excited about it."
"Just turned 25, young as fuck."
Yes you are, Matt Loberstein.
"But geeze, the kid who asked
me for advice is, like, 16.
The fact that you're thinking
about entrepreneurship
at that age is so incredible."
"Daily Vee is the reason
I started my own channel.
Thanks, Gary."
I'm going through a
really interesting time.
You know, it's Jewish New Year now.
Reset.
Some of us are able to reset twice a year
(laughs) with New Year's.
Actually all of us, with our different
religions and things of that nature.
Anyway, nonetheless... (claps)
I'm becoming unbelievable critically...
Unbelievably critical and
auditing myself on a daily micro,
but I'm very passive and all
bought into myself at a macro.
This continues to be my theme, right?
Micro speed, macro patience.
I just...
If I could do anything right
now, in this whole 29, 21...
All these themes that I'm telling you.
Too many of you are
judging yourself daily,
and that's coming at the expense of
being patient at a high level.
Excuse me, too many of you are...
I'm sorry, start that again
and keep it this way, Babin,
'cause I like the stream of thought.
Too many of you are being passive daily,
but judging yourselves by the years.
I'm the reverse.
I'm judging myself every
minute, here, right now.
Like, I just let that phone call go by,
and I'm like "What did I just miss?"
Like, every second, hyper.
But I'm patient at the
macro, which makes me happy.
That's kind of, like...
I'm trying to really get this out of me.
Like, daily daily daily speed,
yearly yearly yearly patience.
There's something here,
my friends, that is at
the core of my success that
I'm trying to pass to you.
And in this shortened episode,
I'm just gonna leave you
with that unbelievable
passionate push one more time.
I know this is probably gonna
be a series of three rants,
please fucking figure this out.
There's something here.
(calm hip hop music)
"Babin" rhymes with a lot of stuff!
"Stabbin'"...